اهتزت مصداقيه بي بي سي احدى اكثر
المؤسسات وثوقا في بريطانيا بعد ان وجدت
نفسها وسط سجال اعلامي اثرته تغريده لاشهر
مذيعها فبعد نهايه اسبوع حافله بانسحابات
جماعيه من صحفيين ومذيعين من برامج القناه
اضطرت بي بي سي لدعوه جاري الى العوده الى
العمل بعد تقديمها اعتذارا رسميا له
جانبه قبل الاعتذار ووافق على العوده لكن
تداعيات الجدل لم تنتهي بعد رغم اعتذارها
الا ان القناه تقول انه سيلتزم بتعاليم
القناه التحريريه ولكن ما هي هذه التعاليم
الحياد كما تقول القناه لكنها ليست المره
الاولى التي يعبر فيها صحفيون في البي بي
سي عن ارائهم السياسيه التي يقولون انها
ابسط حقوقهم المدنيه وعلى راسها حريه
التعبير المضمونه في بريطانيا
جدل بشان القواعد التي تريد بي بي سي
فرضها على موظفيها ومذيعيها فيما يخص
استخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بما في
ذلك جاري الذي يربطه عقد خاص بالبي بي سي
من الان وحتى مراجعه التعاليم سيلتزم جاري
بالارشادات التحريريه كان من الصعب الوصول
الى التوازن لكن مطالبه
في تلك اللحظه
لحريه التعبير قيمه كبيره بالنسبه
للبريطانيين في البلاد ولكن من جهه اخرى
يرى المدافعون عن الحكومه ان تشبيه
ليونيكور سياسه بلاده بالنازيه امر حساس
ويتجاوز المقبول به في حريه التعبير وبين
هذا وذاك يضيع التركيز على مضمون القضيه
الاساسيه وهي قوارب الهجره غير النظاميه
والتي اصر لنكر على اعاده التذكير بها رغم
الجدل الواسع الذي اثرته تغريده السابقه
من لندن ع روب عبد الحق العربيه